I'm a very warm welcome to this latest
edition of talking Germany the show
where we do just that and today we're
going off-road to get some breathtaking
sports action because my guests here in
the studio is a professional mountain
bike rider one of Germany's best indeed
and here he is in person aamir kabani I
mean thank you very much for joining us
here today on talking Germany sure it's
wonderful to have you here now I can
guarantee you you can look forward to
some fascinating footage as we get a
feel for army a sport where he
specializes in what's called free riding
and in particular the disciplines of
park slope style and dirt he'll be
explaining all those terms to us and
much more besides the one thing that is
for sure is that this is a sport that
requires massive determination a
dedication athleticism and above or
courage amia thank you once again for
being here we're going to talk about all
the technical stuff in a little bit but
I want to begin by talking about you how
are you I'm actually doing really good
considering that I injured myself two
months ago actually pretty bad and I was
pretty pretty lucky and I'm pretty happy
to be here and be in one piece it was
tell us the story because when you say
you were injured pretty badly yeah it
was more serious than that really wasn't
it yeah i mean i broke my back so that's
something really serious especially for
us riders some people had had not as
much luck as me and I know how close it
was or how kind of you know yeah and so
I'm really happy considering this
situation sir okay so let's have a look
at we've got some photos that we can see
exactly what happened yeah I'm gonna
tell us exactly what was going on there
well it's right after after day the
crush I mean I didn't you I was working
on a new trick and I landed on my
straight on my head after like you
landed on your head yeah right with my
with my yeah with my head in the crown I
guess it was around 4 meters maybe and
there was a big impact big pain for my
for my whole body and so that's like the
days or the fifth day in hospital I was
able to walk again with this said quote
oh good like a corset course I yeah I
think and yeah that was already this
kind of thing that you can't walk or
can't move for five days there was a
horrible feeling for me I wasn't sure
and the beginning of the of the recovery
it wasn't sure that I need an injury or
not so i wasn't sure if i'll be able to
ride it as as good as before what the
when you were lying there on the ground
and you were getting the the initial
treatment yeah you must have been
feeling really powerless and you must
have what thoughts were going through
your head what but what was the worst
suit case scenario for you at that point
in time okay I can't really tell you
exactly i was just too many thoughts i
was i was scared I was oh I was heard
everything was hurting it was a crazy
pain going from my body and I didn't
really know what's going on and I was
just waiting for the painkiller and then
to come down so I didn't really wanted
to think too much during this situation
because I already knew I don't want to
overthink it while it's bad you know
yeah and this was this was an accident
that took place during training your
sport the sport season is now on you are
out of action yeah where yous are you
doing well in terms of getting back to
training now yeah I'm actually doing
really good I mean since since two weeks
now I'm actually able to do my normal
daily like the usual things you know
yeah just do the basic things and then
and I just pretty much started two days
ago to do some some slow cross country
runs on the street and actually get to
do some yes easy exercises so that
that's really cool for me I mean that's
a really good good star to getting the
right direction yeah so it all sounds so
rational and uncertain and so clear in
your head but I'm just wondering I mean
you're a young guy you've fallen from
four meters onto your head you've broken
your back you must be asking yourself at
some stage why am I doing this well it's
that's a thing I don't want to think of
too much I mean I I ask myself do I want
to keep doing this right and I said yes
so I don't want to overthink the whole
situation so that's just my way I will
deal with it with the injury and just
that makes me heal way faster no doubt
yeah bigger motivation fishing a
motivation yeah okay well maybe there
you've had your first impressions from
army are there here is more America
bonnie is in his element in the
prize-winning web video in the woods he
struts his stuff jumping over all sorts
of obstacles the 24 year old extreme
athlete makes his living with stunts
like this
the [ __ ] does month effect all you need
is some wood and a bit of dirt to build
a jump and fly over it with your bicycle
is indescribable that's what makes our
sport special that you can fly through
the air on a bicycle it's very cool
kabani started mountain biking when he
was 13 at 16 he took part in his first
competitions and soon decided to turn
pro now he's one of the world's top
dirtbike riders dirt bikes are special
mountain bikes they're small and
maneuverable it's not about speed it's
about technique and the difficulty of
the jumps and the disciplines of
free-riding and slope style
cabanas hometown is buffered on the
Rhine he grew up here with three
siblings his mother is German and his
father is a doctor from Syria his
parents weren't enthusiastic about his
choice of career at first now they're
proud of his success
the highly specialized bikes made of
carbon fiber and aluminum cost up to six
thousand euros kabani gets the various
parts from his sponsors and assembles
the bikes himself he practices his
stunts several hours a day on a circuit
he built himself an inn nearby forest
this is a backflip and this is a
tailwhip it's from the English
expression tale for the back of the bike
I hold a bike by the front end and do a
complete rotation with the back seams at
Emma home kabani practiced this
technically difficult stunt for two
years free riders often fly 10 meters at
great speed there's a great risk of
injury helmets and protectors are
compulsory
the extreme athlete wants to remain in
international competition until he's 30
and today he's our guest on talk in
Germany America Bonnie
almere when you're in doing one of those
really spectacular jumps and you're
flying through the air and you're at the
top of the jump what are you thinking
I'd say I'm not thinking too much I'm
just you know focusing on my trick or
even enjoying the air time or being
upset out your knife set down I mean
it's just a cause feeling ever bet it is
yeah you see it's not a feeling I'm ever
going to know let's go back to you your
your early days yeah you were a you were
a sports mad youngster what's it you
will you were really very very
interested in sports when you were a
young boy you tried all sorts of
different sports yeah pretty much I went
for everything i went i did tennis i did
judo edit swimming and everything just
got bored after some time so why yeah i
don't just something was missing
something was missing her then one day
when you were 13 years old yeah you see
a couple of guys coming round the corner
and down the hill or up the hell i don't
know where they were going and and you
thought huh tell me about that yeah that
was just some guys with some to moodle
helmets and stuff and I just thought
that's so cool there might be doing
something cool or dangerous and I was
young kid so I just I just followed them
and that was the time when I felt in
love right away with this board and when
I saw those guys she's flying around
with the bicycles I mean this is too
cool he thought it was exciting cool and
dangerous and the dangerous you thought
danger is good yeah not not really i
wouldn't i wouldn't even say that i can
actually remember the day when I or the
first time when I started I was even
scared of doing this but it was just too
cool for me so like I just really wanted
to do this kind of sports oh I just got
used to it and just got more comfortable
so less Garrett you were a 13 year old
guy and Ivor I've read about you that
you were you were the kind of guy who
would how are you doing at school of
that telling actually not too bad no I
mean not to bed i wasn't really focusing
focusing on it I mean cuz i'm told that
you were the kind of guy who finds it
you know i mean i'm watching you sitting
here you're sitting very very calmly and
it on a television show but I'm told
that when you were a youngster you were
the kind of guy who found it very
difficult to sit still yeah yeah true so
yeah that's there's actually pretty true
but I'm very sure that this sport or
mountain biking itself just helped me
like a lot because i was just riding
every day and i just put every Power i
had just into the sport so next day I
was just really tired from from riding
the day before so I was more chilled
unless ok you decided when you were 17
years old I think that you wanted that
this is what you wanted to be doing for
a career you wanted to become a
professional rider yeah and you were you
told your parents first of all I presume
yeah not happy yeah not not too happy in
the beginning happy I mean they were
kind of recognizing what direction I'm
going that I'm actually focusing so much
on those things on this sport so they
kind of had a feeling maybe I wasn't
telling too much but one day I came to
my dad and just said dad I got the
opportunity I can move to Munich there's
a big indoor place I want to practice
there and want to turn pro like the
whole way and he didn't say too much it
was just like I don't know he said ok
dude you went to Munich he was 17 years
old why why Munich specifically did you
have somebody there who's gonna be
training you or somebody who you could
link up with because because the time I
moved there there was like a massive
endure in no place like a big in the
hall so we had like perfect
opportunities to practice didn't really
matter what time or so that was pretty
perfect and all my sponsors were there
so ok so easy and then you began to
establish it so you you were you were a
professional when you were 17 years old
and you began to establish yourself in
the sport how does that work do you join
a team do you join a club or what are
the structures well it's pretty much
myself I mean there's always friends who
you ride with but i'm i'm writing for
myself and i'm competing for myself for
my success ok and you're a professional
where does the money come from does it
come from do you know
it is it prize-winning mummy all depends
is that's quite a few things you can do
you could either way right shows or you
can win prize money or you get money
through that video confuse or or mainly
your sponsors that's what pays your
random stuff okay and you are there in
your sport are there superstars are the
sort of figures who are you know who are
earning pots of money who are
internationally recognized figures well
I'd say there's quite a few Americans
who made really good money considering
the size of the sport we are doing so
there's actually there's definitely some
guys who make good money yeah I'm doing
okay to so nothing to complain about
good I'm I said at the beginning of the
show that the three things are very
important for your sport one is
dedication that means you sort of lived
for the sport one is athleticism yeah
and the other one is courage which of
those three is the most important I'd
say these days is I mean today's may
probably a 10 years ago was more like a
free status board and now it gets more
and more important that you actually
focus and have you know like all the
energy to put in there and it's just
like you need all kinds of thing things
I mean you need to have like your mind
needs to be free you you have to
practice way harder than the years
before and it just needs a good mix of
everything courage is very important
though clearly because I mean I know
that you have said about you your sport
is viewed as an extreme sport and I
think the problem with extreme sports
these days is that they're becoming more
and more extreme you can't stand still
you can't say well I can do that trick
or i can do that routine because the
next day somebody's going to come along
and go one little bit further but you go
a little bit further and the risk is
greater or you get better I mean there's
progression on on two sides I mean it's
not only about the riders in the crazy
tricks the bikes are getting better
they're getting lighter there's more you
can do maybe more trick so can add
another trick or another combination it
has influence from different sides so
it's
only about going crazier and crazier
every year um there's a guy in your
sport he's been a big name in recent
years called Tarek Rizzoli tell me his
story well tarak tarak is right now he
is like the main organizer of every
European event and he was used to ride
bikes to like really in the the first or
early days and yeah he had a big
crashing right now he's sitting in a
wheelchair after that it's a tough story
that's a tough story and he was one of
the first guys who called me when I was
lying hospital but that's interesting
but um yeah i mean he's also a friend so
mmhmm yeah we had some good moments to
talk about it but sure it's yea though
it is that's how it is you said you save
yourself I i I've read about you saying
I get frightened I have nightmares
sometimes it's just it's just when you
love something so much did you spend the
most of the time for thinking about it
even when you want to sleep you know
it's just it's too much in your head you
too much I'm too much mountain bike not
to do it you know so it's in your blood
it's in your head it's it's yeah I don't
know I don't know how the other guys
doing but that's me it's interesting
because I could ask you a really
interesting question now it will seem
very funny to you you're 24 years old
here are you old for your sport other
you know because you've been in your
sport for you know set what seven years
now yeah are there now young guns young
kids coming up putting you under
pressure who were like 18 19 and who are
willing to take greater risks who are
willing to push the envelope still
further well there's always new comers I
mean but it's just I mean I've been in
this sport for around seven or eight
years or in the in the contest seen and
I've seen people coming and going and
actually people who got too old who left
or did less I feel this I recognize this
but right now I'm I'm still right in it
there's people who are 30 or older and
so I'm doing still pretty good yeah good
for you okay Amir Kabbani who is right
in it has been
involved in an ongoing film project with
a photographer and filmmaker called
Lucas Teal'c em and what they've come up
with his is pretty spectacular to put it
mildly the first film was in the woods
that was the name of it and because that
one went down so well they followed it
up with you've guessed in the woods too
so let's get a feel for what it's all
about
well
d
I'm so
mormon out
no silly
I
yourself too
Oh
amia that's interesting that's a great
film I year I watched all of it at home
yeah once on my own and then another
time with my son and with my daughter
they were very impressed at the end of
the film we see you there planting a
tree now why what's all that about well
I'm just I love nature and I love the
woods I love being in the woods that's
why the title and for me the beginning
of the movie we want to create a story
around the movie so i cutted that tree
and at the end we see you max yeah you
take an axe to the tree yeah did you
make the logo and stuff and at the end I
just planting new tree because I thought
it's a good idea ok so that makes you
sound like a sort of a green country boy
yeah but it also really it also gives me
the feeling that you have a little bit
of a bad conscience I mean your sport
has an impact on nature yeah what are
really really tiny one compared to
anything else I mean that's not I'd say
there's nothing actually that you have
to talk about like it's we don't we
don't have motorbikes we don't have
engine we don't lose oil or anything we
don't destroy anything really so are you
ready I'd I was asking the question a
little bit because i'm a walker i'm a
mountain walker myself and very off to
the people in the mountains they
complain about those guys on the on the
mountain bikes i know that but we'll
leave that one how did your your
partnership with lucas tioga come about
well um Lucas is just a really really
really good guy and we just met years
ago and he started with some small
projects and stuff we pretty much
started our first video project with in
the woods free which is yeah now three
years ago and the time he got bigger I
got bigger and we just yeah focused on
projects together and yeah so it's been
a really really good in success the film
is like a you know it's a 67 minute film
yeah how how long does it take to make
what is a relatively short but pretty
sort of high-class film yeah how much
work goes into it yeah the second one
took like a really really long time
considering the duration it got so for
those six minutes it's a little bit less
a little bit more than six minutes it
took
and five weeks maybe maybe six to film
this this quality and yeah and that's
that it in the film there's the
wonderful jump for example you do across
the kind of I don't know what it is
quite like a river yeah the river yeah
I'm sorry how far did you actually leap
there I think I was around 12 meters
maybe boof yeah that's big jump and did
you actually say to you say hey Lucas
I'm gonna go up there and I'm gonna do
the jump you put the camera here and you
go up and do it or do you you know how
many times do you have to do it to get
it right too well I mean Lucas doesn't
have that doesn't have the time to be
there all the time so I built this jump
for example this river jump before he he
comes to me and I say hey I want to
shoot this and so we go there and well
the first try is always the the the most
interesting one that's for sure yeah and
it's it's interesting just tell me how
you know I we're talking about jumps you
explained the backflip you explained the
tail flip these are really difficult
jumps and they take quite a long time to
learn how do you learn them what's the
process well that's that's basically
well those those tricks are the basics
to go crazy and crazier for the tricks
you need to do today so for those tricks
or especially for tricks well you've
been upside down there's foam pits so
there's like a big pit of foam yeah what
and in front of the this pit there's a
kicker so you can actually get a feeling
for the for the movement and land soft
even if you land bad or jump off your
bike it's not really dangerous so you
get a feeling not only for the trick
they're also how to escape over out of a
trick to make it longer distance or to
go shorter and all those kinds of things
what you need to get a feeling for
before you do it on a real Pachter jump
ok what were what I still haven't
understood is when you're actually in
competition yeah you're doing you're
doing tricks yeah and somebody has to
judge how well you are doing those
tricks is there like a jury is it like
inside oh no what it like an ice dancing
there are four people who say I'll give
him so in so many points is that how it
works yeah there's always is
which needs to be at least three people
and those three people had to be
qualified for this or they went to
school or judging clinic to be able to
do this kind of job okay what kind of
safety gear do you wear I mean obviously
wear a helmet when you're going at high
speed yeah what else what else do you
wear to make sure out of this safe and
said yeah if I started here or I always
wear ankle guards which are like to
support your ankle when you catch tricks
or just you know don't do hurt the ankle
then there's shin guards I'll go to chin
pads off the shin pads yeah it's like
really big one so you can't really hurt
you know what your muscles or you shin
and for sure it's super important is
good knee pads yeah for big impact I
mean you need you don't want to destroy
your knee and then depends on what kind
of trick i'm doing i wear elbow pads
gloves and a helmet and depends on how
big the jumpers i'll start with the full
face helmet but the full face helmet
what people don't see isn't always the
safer room because you see less you have
less feeling or control on your bike so
when they see us just wearing a skate
helmet it's not only about being cool
it's about having more you know to see
more okay and how is your bike different
from the kind of mountain bike that you
might catch me cycling on yep I'd say
because it's it's way smaller and it's
super light it only has a rear brake
because we don't really need a front
brake the end on one gear won't get only
one gear yeah uh-huh okay and I what I
need from you is also a definition of
some terms because we've used these to a
free ride means what yeah free ride
price basically explains the whole thing
it doesn't matter if you write contests
if you only write jumps or if you if you
go somewhere crazy fruit through the
forest it's just being free i mean free
writing similar to ski okay so there and
then there are some other category
slopestyle park and dirt so yeah dirt is
basically only made of third which means
there's a star tower where you get your
speed and then there's a rhythm line of
jumps just in a row and that's dirt
jumps and slope says kind of more way
also
have drops and like different different
kind of obstacles just just a
combination out of park and and dirt
that's lobster and park is it's from BMX
is yeah Rams and quarter pipes and those
kind of things it's great to see your
enthusiasm as you talk about your sport
wonderful yeah
we haven't talked about the fact that
you are Syrian German or what what how
do you see it yourself am I do you call
yourself Syrian German German Syria not
German simply I'm curious what I'd say
if people ask me are you German or you
look different or you know you look you
have some different background I would
say I'm German but my dad is from Syria
so because I can't really say I'm half
serious is there's not you know there's
not enough influence you know like
you're a very German Syrian person I
would have to say I don't know a very
German person and your father why did he
come to Germany originally because he
studied and ok met my my mom in love
he's gonna love so you came here to
start he met my mom and then yeah just
ok that's it that's a nice story a less
nice stories the story of the war that
has been going on in in in Syria for the
last three years what kind of you know
what kind of impact has it had on your
life you must think about this some
times where I just kind of you know
realize it as its way closer to me then
to other people who accuse my dad is
from Syria and he got family there and
still farming family there and for
example my cousin who lives in Germany
he's also a doctor he brought his like
my uncle and my aunt to Germany to to
get them as safe alive and and made sure
that that he will take care of all the
payments and everything to have them
here in Germany to protect them so
that's something i probably can't
compare with the feelings my dad has
because I'm German I don't know too much
about the whole thing because I just
don't have this feelings he got with his
family because I don't know them do you
must be thinking about it a lot at the
moment there I mean it for me I watched
the images on television and I hear
what's happening and I work around the
story from the German anglers it as a
journalist yeah and it's a terrible war
do you do guys at home to you and your
father the rest of the family do you
talk about it so
x sometimes I'd say my dad is a quiet
guy so he doesn't really want to talk
too much about it yeah he's probably
trying to deal with it in some sort of
away yeah I mean it's also the fact that
we he knows that we don't have the same
feelings like him so it's just a waste
of something you know yeah he has to
focus on the things he would like to
realize and support his family and do
all the good things he can do from where
he is right now yeah and what about you
have you actually ever visited Syria
twice but I was I was I was really young
when i was around 11 10 11 so I was too
young to really yeah I get a real
feeling about this country and hold
everything when I just have like really
small hmm memories and how do you it was
interesting as we talked a lot we talked
a lot on this show we talked a lot at
Deutsche Welle we talked a lot in
Germany about the questions of
integration it must seem strange to you
as somebody you're a German you've lived
in Germany all your life and people
sometimes say to you you just mentioned
it say to you where do you come from
that must seem weird well it's weird
because people yeah I don't know it's
hot it's a hard question i mean people
don't know or maybe don't even care too
much where you're from or where your
region is or how the whole thing works
and stuff so I know I'm here I'm German
people are like away from I'm like I'm
born here I don't know too much about
Syria but I'm proud to have this
background I mean it's nothing bad it's
a good thing so oh great great great
attitude wonderful best way to do with
the problem yeah
tell me a little bit more about Bob hard
on the Rhine pop it on Ryan that's
that's the place where I grew up and
yeah it's the the place I love because I
just kind of from time to time I
recognized more and more whole how cool
it is for me and for my sport and and
yes it's actually super pretty yeah I
don't know I just I just pretty much
realize that that there's so many
tutorials and stuff we get used to it
but sometimes you know always get like
feeling that some some people who who
visit you to say what is this what it is
in LA I start telling we got tons of
castles and is in this and the wine so I
kind of remember myself how cool this
places when you were living in Munich
for those three years when you went to
be unique to train down there did you do
miss papad yeah for sure I mean I was I
was 17 I was not only missing Bob I also
my parents and my friend so I wasn't
really a big decision to say I'm going
back for me the big thing that I have
discovered about sort of finding out
about you and listening to what you've
been talking about today is that your
sport involves two things and maybe
three things what one thing is being
very fit as fit as possible the other
thing is what the things you do on the
on your bike and the other thing is what
you do with this yeah we like to invite
our guests to bring along a possession
with them until tell me why you've
brought this along or tell our viewers
why you brought this along well yeah
that's debt to shovel that's you know
it's a shovelful for other people that's
probably only a shovel but for me it's
like a tool a tool i use super often and
what's super important for me and this
one for example this is i bought this
one America and it's like for me it got
the perfect J shuffle in America no I
ordered it from America okay so I didn't
go there so Germany can't make shovels
like this now it seems like every
country has the own shape of shovel or
different shapes and this is just the
perfect shape for me and the stuff I
built so yeah I decided to take one of
those
it and we were talking about Bob hard
yeah and it's interesting you have some
kind of arrangement with the authorities
with the city fathers or the city
mothers in Bob hard yeah that they they
say in a very underman way you can go
out there and go on the hills and do
what you do yeah yet kind of I mean
there's like a official bike park I I
started to build up before i move to
Munich and whoa just leaving um so I
kind of I mean for those three years
there was a break I didn't I couldn't
really take care of the whole thing but
once I got back I I took care again of
the whole thing and make sure that there
is no garbage and everything is good and
there's stuff for amateurs and stuff so
they say okay you take care of it but so
you can kind of have you freedom I have
their my line for my practice and
everything so it's kind of a cool
arrangement I got with those guys I make
sure that everything is fine and sounds
good okay we started with your with your
injury we started with your accident and
I'm still curious about whether the time
that you have had off from the sport has
been a time of reflection yeah what have
you discovered about yourself at this
time I definitely kind of got a way
better connection to my body I pretty
much started realizing how close my head
and my body kind of connects together
and how important you had is for for the
healing process so that's what I
definitely realized and it's just yeah I
kind of have a better yeah feeling which
is so important now which I'm really
looking forward to yeah okay and you
still have the ambition of staying in
the sport until you're 30 or so you know
what is your what is your goal in those
years well for sure for this year my
goal is to finish this video project
project which i have been working on for
so many ones yeah and I want to finish
this and don't want to put too much
pressure on myself right now to say I'm
going to write a contest next and the
next two months because I'm not sure my
it needs to be there I need to be fit
for this and even if it's after one
month I'm going there because I want to
do this so i wanna i want to realize a
few different creative video projects
and my contest for sure okay wonderful
we're going to round off now i'm here
with our two typical talking germany
quiz at the end of the program get sort
of alternatives big city or small town
small towns yeah sure uphill or downhill
daniel how fast do you go when you're
going downhill top speed I have no idea
depends on the track so I'd say 250
maybe I don't know actually digging or
jumping jumping yep uh what's tougher
going down a mountain on a mountain bike
or sitting still for 45 minutes on a
talk show yeah sitting still on a talk
show that's a [ __ ] you've done a good
job there well done here that's all the
time we have this for this time round on
talking Germany our guest a man with a
pole Sean for danger the brave and
charming are me acaban if you've enjoyed
this company as much as I have come by
next week bye bye just